hey guys how's it going happy
Valentine's Day today I thought I would
treat myself and I got myself a present
I read in the comments I asked you guys
what hand mixer I should use because the
one that I was using before I was so
just beyond awful this thing's a piece
of crap I need to get a better one leave
me some comments and suggestions on what
hand mixer to get because this thing
sucks this is what I needed
Rome also had been telling me she's like
why don't you have a hand mixer and I'm
like girl don't even ask me those
questions cuz you've been in my kitchen
you know how things go here so I'm gonna
do a nice little unboxing and then we're
going to bake an amazing celebratory
Valentine's Day cake for you to make for
your loved one or your not loved one or
really just whatever you want to do I
think this is gonna be a really great
treat look at this oh yeah this is gonna
be great oh I'm so excited let's bake
this cake I should probably wash these
first
everything is very sanitary I love
pulling my hair up before I cook food
you guys yeah let me look at my balloon
it's just like a little added flavor a
couple extra beautiful blonde luscious
strands in your meal I don't even tell
you guys what I'm making today I'm gonna
be making a bleeding-heart cake and it's
gonna be incredible in my mind it sounds
and just it looks beautiful but I don't
know what's gonna happen well I got
myself another present I got myself some
new bowls look how pretty gosh I'm so
domestic it's like wow hey are you gonna
not mess something up today
no promises we're gonna make a nice
little strawberry one because it's
Valentine's Day so it's you know pink
and beautiful and love and stuff let's
make sure I don't mess this up one cup
water one day I'm gonna stab myself and
it's not gonna be pretty okay let's put
our oil in egg one egg two egg three all
right I've never used this before okay
[Music]
now we'll plug it in and then we're
gonna beat this cake mix up baby
it's my first time this is so cool
[Applause]
let's let's boost her up
why didn't I get one to be sooner
good president Racine you're a great
gift giver you should get yourself more
gifts more look at this so cool how fast
let's go let's boost it up that's his
full speed ahead baby
ok ok ok stop we're ready I'm gonna
spray this up great now we're gonna dump
this in here put this baby in the oven
oh my goodness if you make this for your
lover your lover's gonna be like wow I
love you trust me things are gonna get
so much better here very very soon into
the oven we go so well that's making of
many of things ready to start decorating
be right back okay we're back I've got
my cakes but first I need to make this
icing so basically I've got a lot of
plans and I'm not really sure if they're
gonna work but that's usually what
happens here so I bought this it slipped
icing mix things got a light taste and a
fluffy texture okay it's available so
this is gonna be our filling for the
cake
this smells incredible like what like
really good so I need 2/3 cup of ice
water here we are this is it
[Music]
rice water mix on low speed for one
minute should I got to use my mixer
again yes so we're also gonna have some
food dye because this is gonna be the
blood this is the inside of the heart
this is how we bleed I use that in tight
this isn't I used almost all of it this
was brand new that's way too much that's
way too much
[Music]
notice this is red wow I don't even know
what to say
this is this is not good for you at all
I have a friend who's allergic to red
food dye cut this will put her over the
edge
we're getting there it's getting real
nice and light and fluffy
it looks really good - man I've ruined
it with so much food coloring it's
consistency is really it's really
shaping up to be something that that I'm
liking I am incredibly impressed with
the consistency of this like this became
super fluffy I didn't really believe it
but now that I'm seeing it believe it
now we've got our filling I wonder if it
tastes good wow you're really really
good it's super fluffy like it says it's
fluffy
you don't believe it until you try it I
wasn't you guys could try it I'm so
sorry
come to my bakery open tomorrow oops
just getting burned down and now for the
magic of the cake it's a surprise I
actually made two cakes because what I'm
gonna be doing is I'm cutting one in
half which will be the top and bottom of
our cake and this one is gonna be sort
of the middle so I'm gonna hollow this
out and fill it up with our blood icing
so good so let's see got a level one off
with our cake leveler this thing is
beyond impressive so this thing is so
cool like you just basically just shave
away the top of your cake to make it
super even and super little
okay here we go
now this is gonna be super tricky so one
of these is gonna be on top of the cake
one's gonna be the bottom of the cake
it's very very fragile very very very
fragile please do not break please do
not break look how good I'm so impressed
and this is the cake they're gonna be
filling with blood no better way to say
I love you that a bleeding heart level
this baby off like I have to try it
I gotta taste it to make sure it's good
[Music]
don't worry it's good gone this is where
it gets tricky because I've got to
somehow carve out this heart inside of
the heart
[Music]
I'm gonna put this on top of this one
oh so proud oh god oh god that's gonna
be incredible bruised eye bruised very
very very easily it might not have
looked like that hurt but my god
I'm gonna have internal bleeding cake is
prepped everything looks good we've got
our heart filling so we're just
basically filling this up we're putting
the blood and the love into this heart
let's fill it up filling up the heart
with love write that song if you guys
try to steal it I will put a copyright
claim on your channel just put a little
this icing here just to hold everything
together this is so much icing like I'm
starting to like twitch just thinking
about eating it let's put on the top
look at this oh oh I'm so proud of
myself myself look at this guy's really
investing in our future here the future
is cooking and not destroying things now
we're gonna put on some strawberry icing
it to ice this baby up and then that's
it the cake is complete and it is going
to be a success I mean the way that
things are going now they're going very
very well so let's not jinx it
we need to cover the sides as well of
course I bought three just in case
hmm the heart shape is sort of
disappearing it's okay we can work on it
this is sold much icing like I can't
even believe it
this is taking a very long time to ice
but perfection it takes time things are
going very very very well I'm finishing
up some of the finishing touches on this
bad boy you know I was trying to make it
perfect but I thought you know love's
not perfect so why should the cake be
perfect that's what I call excuses but
it looks good now we're gonna add some
sprinkles these are really pretty this
looks actually really good hmm okay I
wanted to try this it's a color mist
spray oh yeah
holy moly quite what I was going for but
I'm not really sure Oh God
oh wow it's like a mist what just
happened
God that was incredible it looks really
good though
it's like spray paint but edible so my
cake looks like it's pretty much done
I'm pretty happy with how it turned out
I've got like some blood splatters on it
and everything just what I was hoping
for now I just need to wait for my
sister to come over so that she can try
it because I cannot try this alone
because someone else has to be here to
experience this cake and especially if
it's successful so be right back
Jenna's here the time is now she has no
idea what to expect
in this cake what do you think is inside
this cake I don't is it an object or
edible it's edible is that like a
raspberry goo it's pretty good guess
let's give it a cut and see I hope it's
raspberry ready oh just cut good doesn't
be a big slice I want you to really
enjoy the cake hurry up I gotta see what
it is
in the raspberry wasn't it look at that
Wow
such a sizing yep that's a ton of icing
well I was picturing it as it would just
like bleed out but it's not doing any
bleeding get your hair away from my cake
I mean that's a lot of icing this is my
kind of cake yeah that's a lot that is a
lot I think I'm just gonna on take a
bite out of your piece because that's a
huge piece of okay I'm sick let's be
clear I think I got it from you is true
uncle first done wait whoa the best part
look at this oh my oh my god yeah those
are all the sprinkles I'd be careful cuz
they might hurt your teeth what kind of
accident is it it's light and fluffy
there's a very light and fluffy on the
bar there's no we look read it light
taste and fluffy texture that's the best
advertising because it's exactly what
they advertised as advertised what do
you think I mean this is actually yeah
that's pretty good
probably one of the best cakes I've ever
made it's the icing on top different the
icinga table is different
oh yeah be careful oh yeah that's um
that's something it's crunchy I like the
icing on the top better only because I
prefer the real sugary goodness nice but
I wanted it to be like a nice contrast I
know what the guys in fluffy this is
strawberry on top
it's Robert Isaac it's good it's a
really nice cake can do it a great job
I'm proud well thank you guys so much
for watching and happy Valentine's Day
you could make this for your lover you
could make this for your not lover this
is a real Dexter style cake it was not
what I had visions I have envisioned as
you would cut it it would have bleed out
yeah I didn't do that huh well thanks
for watching see you guys later peace
outs which in return
makes my phone a thousand dollars so
here's what I'm concerned about so if
the base price iPhone is already going
to be probably a thousand dollars what
will that mean if you're out of contract
even though people aren't doing
contracts anymore I'm so confused at how
all of the phone mystery is doing you
these things because it doesn't ever
seem to make sense I feel like I'm